These fries are pretty
good and must be made from Russian potatoes.
Aren't Russia's the best
I'll handle this one.
Relax. Relax. Read. Golden has this.
Are you relaxed?
It's very hard to tell. Their eyes.
So angry. Like winter fox.
How can I help you, officer?
Just a routine check in.
Say, where you fellas headed?
Sisters? Yes.
To visit our sister. It's her birthday.
You guys are brothers.
Would you get your sister for her birthday?
Cause I can not for the life of me figure out what
to get my wife for Christmas television.
You got her a sweater and a television. Wow.
That's very generous.
Nice store.
But where are you really headed?
Step out of the vehicle and keep your hand.
Whoa, whoa. Hey,
Will, you can with the guns.
And I had wool over his eyes.
Target spotted in pursuit.
Exercise caution. But get them.
Get em, cowboy.
Let's go round up some super soldiers.
Go with the bullet.
So you should dance with your enemies.
He just like to buy them violence. wow.
Where did that come from?
Did you have that the whole time?
Why own
No, don't shoot down the
Why don't you dance
Come on, man
You're not
it's jammed
You know what Karl Marx said about machines?
They make men lazy
Stop. Stop.
It's over. Surrender yourself.
Go get him.
Dance!
With the folks out
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Big surprise
Marvel dropped the first teaser
for What If season 3
So we'll break it all down
There's a bunch of Easter Eggs here.
we know what some of the episodes are.
There's a bunch of Spider-Man stuff happening during
what if season 3.
So we'll talk about that.
There were some deleted scenes from earlier episodes
that were supposed to happen during ward off season
two. The sound like they got pushed to whatever Season
three there's even a Spider-Man Easter egg.
During this read Guardian Winter Soldier a clip.
so if you're bummed out
at the lack of Spider-Man during what if season two
it sounds like they're really
bring him back in a big way during season three.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Of course I'll do videos for all the episodes,
just like I'm doing for season two right now.
if you're watching this video, a couple of days after
I posted it, the funny thing is they actually dropped
this teaser trailer for season three before the season
two finale, like the day before.
one of the reasons why they might have done
that is because I believe this is
meant to be an episode
that was supposed to air during season two.
This Red Guardian Winter Soldier episode.
But for whatever reason,
they just deleted to season three.
maybe they just decided that they wanted the seasons
to only be nine episodes total.
But this episode does Now, from a
what if season three episode called
What If Red Guardian has Stopped the Winter Soldier?
So it's not totally clear what he's stopping him
from doing other than killing Bill Foster Goliath here.
it looks like it's happening back during the eighties
based on the models of car they're driving in.
How old they are, like this is a much younger version
of Red Guardian than we've ever seen before.
it is based on Bill Foster's age,
like he's much younger looking
than he was during the Avengers 1980s episode.
so this might be like early eighties in the suit
that he's in makes him seem like he's
just like a regular shield agent.
Maybe he hasn't become Goliath yet,
or maybe he's on a mission for Shield
and just happens to be dressed in the suit.
but if it wasn't clear, this is meant to be in
a different reality from that 1980s Avengers episode.
The other funny thing
you probably realize is that they have this team up
episode here, Winter Soldier and Red Guardian.
Like what if they had to go on a mission together
because they're both from Russia?
Kind of Winter Soldier is Hydra
Red Guardian is regular Russian military
part of the idea is that the Soviets at that time
in history with the Cold War, was ramping up,
knew about Hydra, But Hydra was kind of like their own
specific thing operating inside of the Soviet Union,
not totally associated with the Soviet military
is the same thing with Dreykov in the red room.
like the Black Widow
program was a special part of the Soviet military.
It wasn't part of Hydra,
But because Hydra's whole thing was infiltrating
all these aspects of society around the world.
There were Hydra inside of the red room.
but even though they're treating their team up here
sort of like a funny road trip comedy,
they're actually going to be teaming up again
in live action
during the Thunderbolts movie in present day notice
when Bill Foster stops them.
David Harbor switches between his Russian red Guardian
accent and his regular real life American accent.
Winter Soldier gives them the cover that
they're visiting, their sister Bucky did have a sister.
Her name was Rebecca,
But she's meant to have died when he was very young,
and his motives scarred him growing up.
they reference her a little bit in present day.
He had two unnamed brothers, too,
so they would have had some children of their own
since World War Two grandchildren.
So Bucky does have family out there in present day.
He could eventually visit,
maybe after the Thunderbolts,
like he's slowly
healing his mind, like he's getting better day by day.
though Foster mentions
that he has a wife at this point in history,
they botched their answer,
trying to explain what they're actually doing there.
Bucky says, he's getting his sister a sweater.
Red Guardian says that television
he clocks his shield in the back seat.
They also say that their brothers kind of reminds me
of the Arnold Schwarzenegger twins movie.
Like, yes, of course, your brothers.
You look exactly like, when they take off
the woman that picks up Bill Foster is actually called
Ranger Morales which makes you think of Miles Morales
mother, Rio Morales That might just be a coincidence.
But I do think we'll eventually see
Miles Morales in his family inside the MCU.
They mentioned him during Spider-Man
homecoming in the deleted scene Donald Glover also said
that he had a nephew during the movie, during the
theatrical cut that was meant to be Miles Morales.
So there is a miles Morales inside the MCU,
but I think they're mostly waiting
till after Spider-Man
beyond the Spider-Verse comes out in theaters
do do any like really big live action Miles Morales
stuff as they're Chase continues down the road though
it seems like Reed Guardian keeps trying to stop
winter Soldier from killing Bill Foster
the old fashioned way with a gun he makes a Karl Marx
reference references to dancing with the Enemy.
It seems like he's just happy to be on the mission,
like he doesn't actually care
if it's successful in Bucky.
Just can't stand it.
Like, Come on, dude, seriously, let me kill him
and when a winter soldier punches through their car
door, grabbing the wheel with the car spinning around,
it almost looks like the cars are dancing
with each other, paying off all of Red Guardians
Dancing with the enemy references.
like I said, the Peter Parker Spider-Man
is coming back in a big way during what if season
three there's going to be a big Spider-Man
specific episode where he has to make a big sacrifice.
Avengers Endgame, Iron Man style.
it seems like he's doing some other kind of very save
move here, trying to hold a bunch of stuff together.
And then he's cradling
Aunt May in his arms without his mask on.
So it seems like he reveals his identity to her.
Maybe she's dying again like she was during Spider-Man.
No way home. So our report may again.
some of the other big episodes are the
What if Solder attacked Earth
with Scarlet Witch and Doctor Strange
working together to stop him with their magic?
I think that was also supposed to happen during season
two and they just pushed it to season three as well.
this supposed to be a Black Panther
Namor team up episode paying off the end of Black
Panther will kind of forever remember he's
just waiting for them to ask for their help
because the world wants their vibranium now.
Nemours Whole goal was to eliminate all the surface
dwellers He was just waiting for an excuse to do that.
In this war
that's brewing around Wakanda with the world wanting
their vibranium is going to be his excuse to do that.
but in the what if season three episode
they're supposed to be fighting Hydra together.
So it sounds like Hydra is trying
to get their hands on their by bringing the underwater
vibranium in the vibranium inside of Wakanda.
but it sounds like
Namor is supposed to come back during
what if season three
and there's supposed to be a new night specific episode
where Concha actually winds up choosing Bucky
to become his next avatar instead of Marc Spector?
No idea when that happens In the timeline, though,
when we get more footage
or we learn about more episodes, I'll do more.
What if season three videos?
Hopefully after the season two finale,
the start revealing more details.
Previously I thought that
what if Season three was going to be the final season?
But they said that they were actually developing
What if season four that might have been canceled
when they started pulling their budgets
for all those shows and cutting some of the stuff
that was in development?
Like there was a brief period
where Marvel was developing shows
for like every single character
that you've ever heard of.
So what if season three might be the end of the show?
But they are doing the Marvel Zombies show, which is
sort of based on the idea from what if season one.
But I think it's meant to be completely separate thing.
Like it's not taking place in that universe,
And speaking of Marvel zombies,
it does seem like they are one of the big antagonists
during the What If season two finale,
just based on the clip that they just released,
Zombies.
Sounds like my kind of family
now, Neal.
they haven't said when season
three is going to premiere
I'm assuming it's going to be 2025.
But if they're releasing this clip this soon, it could
actually be surprise releasing at the end of 2024,
the other big reminder is that we do have X-Men
97 episodes coming up in the spring, this spring 2024.
They didn't say exactly when.
So there's some time between March and May probably
my next big video will be for the season two finale.
Click here for that video onto the link as soon as
I post that and click here for all my What If episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!